the first app on this list is the  Philips Hue app now traditionally the  Philips U app can do many many things  and it requires you to go out and also  purchase some sort of Philips products  but specifically for this video what I'm  talking about is the sunrise feature in  the Philips Hue home app basically what  it allows you to do is you have to  purchase a Philips hue light globe and  the Philips Hue bridge to be able to  activate it with your wi-fi system but  it will allow you to mimic the sunrise  and when winter comes around our  productivity significantly drops so by  simply automating the lighting in your  bedroom to turn on at the same time as  your alarm is going to significantly  improve your productivity throughout  that day because you're more likely to  get up when your alarm goes off if you  want to see the full video and all  things architecture related make sure  you hit that subscribe button